[Music]
physically draining
and emotionally exhausting
healthcare workers on the front lines of
the pandemic are being pushed
to the brink too often their work is
only fleetingly acknowledged
the who says there is a global shortfall
of some 6 million nurses it's an
especially big issue in poorer countries
because qualified workers tend to move
abroad for better opportunities
but even in richer nations the work
isn't especially well paid
in germany for example nurses earn 20
percent less
than the average wage
the coronavirus has brought their
experience and faces
to the fore how big a tall is the crisis
having
on healthcare workers
[Music]
welcome to your covet 19 special i'm
chris colbert in berlin
the already tough job for healthcare
workers has only become more challenging
in the pandemic
regardless in which part of the world
here is dw's oliver salat
with his report from the u.s state of
south dakota
south dakota one of america's least
populated states
but yet the virus has spiraled out of
control here like nowhere else in the
u.s
in the city of sioux falls a mask
mandate was put in place recently
without sanctions many citizens remain
defiant
i think it's a good idea that people
wear masks but but some people balk at
the idea of being told to do so i think
what some of the shutdowns are doing and
and the picking and choosing that
they're doing is making it very
difficult for a lot of businesses
like most of the people nowadays like
even elders are not wearing masks
but i think it's for the best like
they're just happy
south dakota now sees the highest
hospitalization rate of the u.s
and there is no relief in sight here at
the avera mccannon hospital the
intensive care unit is at
capacity patients are dying from covet
on a daily basis
putting a big strain on nurses and
doctors
who are increasingly overwhelmed by the
amount of patients they're seeing
every day
icu nurse adam schroeder is one of them
he and his colleagues are working
12-hour shifts trying to save those
who are at the brink of death
a task which comes with a personal toll
we deal with a lot of dying right now
unfortunately
not everybody's recovering how we'd like
makes it a little harder every day
people are coming in
typically requiring lots of oxygen
a lot of them end up getting a breathing
tube
and from there you know it's just a
battle for their life
you talk to their families we do that's
one of the tougher things right now
is especially for code patients we're
not allowing visitors so
talking with families on a daily basis
updating them on what we're doing how
the patient's doing
that's a really big thing right now i
kind of see and understand at his weekly
press conference mayor paul tan-heiken
of the republican party
updates his community about the latest
developments
the mayor has been criticized over his
handling of the pandemic
you've been hesitant in the first place
with a mask mandate
why is it such a challenge for you to
convince your citizens that it's
necessary to wear a mask
in this part of the country i think
there's fierce independence that a lot
of people have
i made the mistake of calling it cowboy
country at one point and people didn't
appreciate that but the point of that
term
meaning we're independent we don't like
people telling us what to do
christina bjorkman wishes for more
government action against the pandemic
in october she lost her husband to covet
19
after a 30-day long struggle at the
hospital
tuesday wednesday thursday she says his
death could have been avoided with
stricter rules
the whole mass mandate got political and
it should have never been political
it should have been a medical thing
and i think it just got so blown out of
proportion
and i think maybe it came from our
president
he started it christina bjorkman is
pinning her hopes now on the
president-elect
and a nationwide mass mandate once he
takes office
before then thousands more could die
from covet 19 in south dakota
and around the rest of the united states
now one indicator for how prepared a
health system is to battle the
coronavirus emergency
is the accessibility of intensive care
here's a look at the availability of icu
beds
in selected countries germany has 33.9
critical care beds for every 100 000
people
in the united states there are 25.8 and
10.6 intensive care beds for every 100
000 people in korea
in india that number is at 7.3
and finally mexico 3.3 beds
the number of intensive care beds is
only one factor having access capacity
is less helpful
when there aren't enough personnel to
tend to them and that's exactly the
problem in many cases let's talk to
someone familiar with the challenges
franz wagner is the head of the german
nurses association he joins me via skype
welcome to dw
now the germany and europe are stuck in
the second wave tell us about the
experiences that nurses and other
caregivers
are reporting back to you
nurses and all health professionals in
germany uh have a heavy burden of
workload
these days because of the pandemic it
has reached
unprecedented levels and they have to
tear take care of many many patients
severely ill patients
we know that many patients die once they
have to be admitted in icu
and in particular at the nursing homes
the residents
are severely ill quite often and many of
them have died and this is puts a lot of
pressure on all health professionals
and in the on the nurses in particular
here in germany there are complaints
that there are not enough nurses to
handle the rising number of covet 19
patients
could one also argue that a pandemic
simply is such an extraordinary event
that
hospitals would be understaffed in any
case
both is true to a degree but primarily
it's that we do not have enough nurses
to take care of patients in normal times
so outside the pandemic
compared to other european countries we
have a much higher workload so more
patients partners
than others and in of course in a
situation like this now in the pandemic
where we have
extreme situations this
shortage reaches a new level
and is worsened by that
and where is this shortage coming from
for many years our governments haven't
invested
in more nurses so we had a
cut of nurse positions in nurse in
hospitals
over the last 15 or started 15 years ago
with a new way of financing hospital
costs
and that has never been revoked and
we have been arguing for more than 10
years that we would need more nurses
and we have in addition we have an aging
workforce so many nurses are going to
retire within the next 12
10 to 12 years so nobody listened to our
complaints and we hope this will change
now
some say it's all about the pay which is
too low for such a demanding job
would more money solve the problem of
there not being enough
healthcare workers money alone
wouldn't be the solution if we ask
nurses what they want most
it is that they say i want to have more
colleagues so i want to reduce my
workload
and then of course on the second or
third place in what they want is
a better salary we have a wide variation
between salaries
in germany different between regions and
different between hospitals
and nursing homes for example so an
increase would be good and our
association
is asking for 4000 euro as a starting
salary for each nurse
now during the first wave of the
pandemic people stood on their balconies
and applauded frontline workers we don't
see any of that right now does that
bother you
not really because you know it is a
pleasant
a pleasant sign or a symbolic gesture
getting some upload but applause but
to be honest we would have more benefits
if you get better payment more positions
for nurses
so this is only a kind of a a token and
even
and some nurses were really angered by
that because they said now yeah
now in this situation where you're
afraid you are giving applause
but uh when in every day when we have
difficult situations when we are
complaining about a high workload we
don't listen we don't hear anything from
you
franz wagner head of the german nurses
association thank you for your insights
time now for your questions about the
coronavirus here's our science
correspondent derek williams
how can we achieve herd immunity if you
can get re-infected
there are plenty of questions about this
pandemic where we still don't have
really clear-cut answers like when
your immune memory of the virus wanes so
much
that you could catch it again that's
happened to a few people
but as far as we can tell not really
very many so far
a number of studies now indicate that at
least in most of us
the average immune response to stars
cove2 remains active
for for at least six months which is
positive
because the average duration of immunity
in individuals
either after they've had cobit 19 or
have received a vaccine against it
that will play a defining role in how
fast we reach herd immunity
however even if we do begin seeing
greater numbers
of re-infections relatively soon it
wouldn't make herd immunity
impossible to achieve just harder
because it's going to take years though
to pin down the average duration
of immunity i'm discussing it now means
that you have to make some assumptions
if we assume for instance
that the duration of immunity and
someone who's vaccinated is short
uh say just a year or two then herd
immunity
will be a lot tougher to reach to get
there
we'd have to vaccinate populations
really really quickly
and on a wide scale because without a
booster shot
many people will start getting sick and
transmitting again
pretty quickly experts say in that
scenario
if coverage doesn't advance fast enough
then soros co2 could become
endemic and seasonal like the flu but at
least in some places
if we assume a more positive scenario
though um
that the duration of immunity provided
by a vaccine
is much longer and and importantly also
that vaccinated people can't transmit
the virus to others
then herd immunity will be easier to
reach because
in a manner of speaking once people have
been vaccinated
they'll stay vaccinated
you